this weekend there was another one of
these so-called save America rallies in
Florence South Carolina now I don't need
to explain to you the irony that if the
people who speak at these save America
rallies were in power we would destroy
America and case in point this
particular rally in Florence South
Carolina Donald Trump was speaking in
theory in support of 2022 candidates now
the funny thing is Trump can really only
talk about himself so there was about an
hour speech shorter speech than normal
actually only about 50 minutes I think
because it was cold out and when it's
cold out Donald Trump's speeches are
much shorter he only allowed the two
candidates to speak for like 30 seconds
each at the very end
um and so it was hard to tell that it
was supposedly a rally support
supporting 2022 candidates uh but it
doesn't matter because it's all about
Trump trump was visibly swollen his both
eyes were were swollen almost completely
shut I still don't understand why that
happens it's a very strange thing but
here is Donald Trump all but confirming
that he's running in 2024. take a listen
take back the Senate and we are going to
take back America and in 2024 we are
going to take back that beautiful
beautiful White House
yeah
I wonder who will do that I wonder I
wonder yeah so listen clearly at this
point Trump's plan is to run unless he
unless he gets sick and his and can't
run you know I mean he's going to be
close to 80 years old at the time no no
one's health is guaranteed uh
statistically speaking when you're
almost 80 your health is less guaranteed
than when you're almost 70 and almost
16. okay I mean we're talking about math
here but it seems pretty clear that he's
going to run if he can and by pretending
you're sort of not yet fully announcing
it he wants to avoid having to file
Financial disclosure reports that's
really the only reason I can think of
not to announce it yet Donald Trump then
beyond parody calls Joe Biden physically
and mentally challenged Joe Biden failed
to deter Russia's outrageous invasion of
Ukraine you could take the five worst
Presidents in American history and put
them together and they would not have
done the damage Joe Biden has done in
just 13 months
we have a president representing our
country at the most important time in
history who is physically and mentally
challenged now there are real uh so the
the guy in The Glass House should not be
catapulting stones at others I think I
don't know that we need to say more
about that
um Donald Trump did address the Russian
invasion of Ukraine but not as such he
vaguely refers to conflict in Eastern
Europe and how lack of respect is a
factor in what's going on he doesn't
really criticize Putin directly like he
he says Putin has been driven to put it
together which is really strange
language it feels as though Trump is
kind of trying to support Ukraine
without really going after Putin
and for all the talk about violent
conflict in Eastern Europe and it's a
terrible thing and we're gonna help and
we're going to do whatever we can
because nobody can look at the Bloodshed
much longer what's happening it's a lack
of respect
for a lot of people a lot of things but
it's just a total lack of respect and it
happens to be a man that is just driven
he's driven to put it together and you
look at it and it's just so ridiculous
and so senseless and so
so yeah I mean when you hear that it's
like I think he's against the Russian
invasion of Ukraine but he says the
issue is respect and Putin's driven to
put it together like why can't he just
straightforwardly condemn the actions of
Putin and Putin himself why is that so
difficult
um then and this is where it really gets
to be Beyond parody Trump takes credit
for giving military aid to Ukraine
ignoring that he was impeached because
he withheld the aid trying to get
zelenski to give him dirt on Biden and
announce an investigation into Biden now
he wants credit for having given the
military aid that he was shamed into
giving to Ukraine remember that with
Ukraine I sent the javelins that you see
are so effective against the tanks
Biden didn't and in fact he ended our
last order probably it'll get there
because everyone realized it was the
right thing to do and Obama remember
Obama Biden they sent blankets I sent
javelins and they said well you know the
Japanese are the anti-tanker yeah the
Jarvis listen Trump tried not to send
the aid to zelenski so that zielinski
would announce that he was investigating
Joe Biden and then he was shamed in
descending the aid because Colonel
vinman Lieutenant Colonel vinman outed
all of it Trump was shamed in descending
the aid now he wants credit for it then
and this is bizarre Trump calls on his
supporters to lay down their lives
to fight critical race Theory
what who would do that and why would you
need to who critical race theorists are
going to kill people who don't like
critical what anything getting critical
race Theory out of our schools is not
just a matter of values it's also a
matter of national survival we have no
choice the fate of Any Nation ultimately
depends upon the willingness of its
citizens to lay down and they must do
this lay down their very lives to defend
their country if we allow the marxists
and Communists and socialists to teach
our children to hate America there will
be no one left to defend our flag or to
protect our great country or its freedom
this is prototypical fascist propaganda
reactionary fascist propaganda imagine
even believing you might even have the
opportunity to die for or I guess
fighting against critical race Theory uh
I it's and this is one of these examples
of critical theory I I am not a critical
theorist I'm not a post-modernist
etc but much like General Mark milley
said it's not about
wanting to before or against these
things necessarily it's about studying
them and understanding them imagine if I
said
I'm willing to die against the teaching
of existentialism you would say David
that's extraordinarily stupid it's not
very different with what they're talking
about with critical race Theory they
don't know what it is
they know they're against it but they
are weaponizing it and you end up The
Logical conclusion is Trump saying you
might have to die against critical race
Theory then remember uh Republicans want
to reduce the power of the president but
here's Trump saying we should add a new
Presidential Power we will pass critical
reform
executive branch employee fireable
fireable by the president of the United
States the Deep state must and will be
brought to heal so Trump openly
promoting the Deep state conspiracy
theory but remember they claim to be for
small government against the president
having too much power but he is saying
no no no no let's give the president
more power to to have any federal
employee be fireable directly by the
president Trump then seemingly confused
about beautiful blood I don't even know
what this means and pure unflinching
courage is coursing through our veins so
beautiful beautiful blood red white and
blue
we will not beautiful red white and blue
blood folks it is a beautiful thing so
Trump's rally in South Carolina
highlighted a few things number one even
rallies meant to be for other people
really are about Trump the the rally was
supposedly for some candidates they
barely spoke until the very end 30
seconds and all they basically had to do
was say how great Trump was it's all
about Trump number two he clearly is
running in 2024 unless something changes
with regard to his health or maybe his
ability to win the nomination if he got
win that he definitely has no shot maybe
he wouldn't run and number three he's
repeating the same unoriginal stuff at
this point and a big part of his appeal
in 2016.
was he was saying new things they were
unexpected they were wild they were
wacky they no longer are that anymore
but there are still quite literally tens
of millions of people who seem okay
voting for the same
failed talking points which if Trump
were to win would lead to Global
humiliation even greater than when Trump
won last time but also absolutely sorry
hit my mic there absolutely nothing
getting done for another four years one
of our sponsors is little spoon your
One-Stop shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price little spoon makes
everything fresh just like homemade but
it's delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop it in the fridge or freezer
and it is ready when you are they have
100 organic cold pressed baby food for
every eating stage awesome food for
toddlers and for kids they even just
launched a new line of on the go
smoothies that kids love everything is
nutritionally balanced is no junk food
but it is kid approved it's food that
they'll actually eat and enjoy and you
can't beat the prices with kids meals
under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience fifty
percent off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below